[تصفيق]
من السيارات إلى ناطحات السحاب
يتم استخدام الواقع الافتراضي في طليعة
التصميم ولكن ما يستغرقه المستحضرات الصيدلانية
من 10 إلى 12 عامًا لنقل الدواء
من مفهوم إلى السوق وغالبًا ما
يوصف بأنه محاولة للعثور على إبرة في
البحث عن كومة قش  غالبًا ما تكون الأدوية الجديدة
عملية طويلة ومكلفة ،
فبعض الأرقام الأخيرة تكلف
حوالي 2 مليار للحصول على سمك السلمون المرقط في السوق ،
لكن هذا ليس لأن تلك الشاحنة استغرقت
ملياري دولار للحصول عليها بسبب جميع
التكاليف الأخرى التي تحملتها.  تم إنفاقه للعثور على
ذلك ، لذا تبحث الشركات باستمرار
عن طرق جديدة لتسريع
عملية
اكتشاف c4x في مانشستر إنكلترا يرى أن
الواقع الافتراضي هو السبب الرئيسي الذي
يجعل الافتراضية مهمة جدًا
بالنسبة لنا أكثر من غيرها هو أن مجموعة البيانات
التي نحصل عليها من موقعنا  تقنية الرنين المغناطيسي النووي حيث
نحصل على هذا التوافق ، هذه المجموعة
من الأشكال لكل جزيء هي
بيانات غنية جدًا لدرجة أنه لا يمكنك النظر
إليها بسهولة على ثنائي الأبعاد أو حتى ثلاثي الأبعاد واحد.
سبلاي أن البيانات رباعية الأبعاد هي ما يميز C 4xd
عن بعضها البعض ، فقد طوروا برنامجًا يسمى
التبصر لتفسيره ، ويستخدم
محرك Unreal Engine نفس النظام الأساسي الذي
يمنح Fortnight ظاهرة ألعاب الفيديو
التي يلعبها الملايين حول
العالم لصياغتها التي تراها لـ XD تحولت
لتشكيل  مطور ألعاب الفيديو يملأ
Wonga لبرمجيات المواقع هو
نفسه لعبة لدينا قاعدة مستخدمين
نحاول حملهم على القيام بالمهام مرارًا
وتكرارًا ويحاولون القيام بذلك
بطريقة ممتعة وبديهية لأنه إذا
تحتاج إلى القيام بشيء ما لمدة ثماني ساعات
يوميًا ، فهذا يساعد إذا كان سهل الاستخدام ، ولكن
لماذا يحتاج العلماء إلى لعبة فيديو
لتطوير أدوية جديدة تسمح
لهم بتفسير شكل وسلوك
الجزيئات من مستوى جديد تمامًا
يقترن بالعقار المناسب  تعتبر الجزيئات التي تحتوي
على البروتينات المستهدفة في جسم الإنسان
أمرًا بالغ الأهمية لعملية التصميم ، حيث
يمكن أن يتسبب الاقتران الخاطئ في آثار جانبية في
قدرة المريض على الانتقال إلى الأشياء
بشكل مستقل باستخدام اليدين وهو أمر
رائع للغاية.  مقارنةً باستخدام جهاز
2d
3c4 XD فقط ، نرى بالفعل
نتائج إيجابية مع عقار جديد لمكافحة
الإدمان يدخل في التجارب السريرية ، ولكن
هناك حدودًا لطول المدة التي
سيرتدي فيها شخص ما سماعة رأس VR ، لذا نرى أن XD
نتطلع بالفعل إلى
تقنيات أخرى نحن  ترغب في
تغطية كل هذه التقنيات حتى نتمكن من جعل
العلماء يعملون في 2D في
الواقع الافتراضي يعملون فيها جميعًا في مساحة مشتركة
عبر الإنترنت وجميعهم قادرون على التفاعل
مع بعضهم البعض وكل هذا
التعاون يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
تطوير الحياة-  ادخار المخدرات
[موسيقى]